- [Narrator] This is the
gallito de las rocas,
the Andean cock-of-the-rock,
also known as “Tunki”
in the indigenous language of Quechua.
Widely-regarded as the
national bird of Peru,
the gallito de las rocas is native
to the Andean cloud forests.
Their most distinct feature
is their beautiful feathers.
While the male has a large crest
and bright orange plumage, the female
is more modest than its counterpart,
with darker-brown feathers.
The brilliant colors help the males
stand out when courting
for a female partner.
At breeding time, males bob up and down
hopping around displaying their charms.
Females watch from branches nearby.
Their feathers have
been an attractive prey
for the black market,
driving the population down.
Because of droughts associated
with climate change,
as well as the massive
destruction of forests,
the future of their longtime home
is now being threatened.
This is the gallito de las rocas.
(uplifting background music)